we're here at the economic forum in
davos switzerland 2016 and it's an
exciting time because it's all about
climate change climate change is one of
the most serious possibly arguably the
most serious consequence that we are now
facing thanks to the Industrial Age and
because of that it's important that we
be able to visualize and understand
transparently how human activity is
changing the world and change the world
in a way that makes it unsustainable so
our visualization tools allow us to zoom
in and show every aspect of climate
change from coral bleaching to
deforestation to cover the oxide around
the world data should become a tool that
we use to inform the way we make
decisions at the citizen level public
level and the governmental level so the
kind of data that we now have available
for the first time bringing together
every layer of data about climates
around the world is the kind of data
that everybody needs to have access to
so now we're taking steps to create
accessibility of this data through the
minister's to the vice president's and
through others here to every population
around the world